well a major major victory on Election
Day yesterday for Democrats yeah there
were elections yesterday Virginia is
going to continue with a Democratic
governor Ralph Northam was elected
yesterday and he will take over for
Democrat Terry McAuliffe certainly
McAuliffe an establishment Democrat if
there ever was one
Northam defeated at Gillespie the
epitome of the establishment Republican
former RNC Chairman roughly 54 to 45 was
the size of Gillespie's loss in Virginia
and North amiss you know on on policy
Northam is right on abortion he's
generally been I guess ahead of centrist
Democrats to some degree on gay rights
he's open to medical marijuana he
recognizes that the war on drugs
disproportionately hurts people of color
he believes in he believes that the way
we're currently enforcing marijuana laws
is absurdly expensive and
counterproductive on education funding
he's uh spot on he wants to fund
education properly at multiple levels
including early childhood education and
pre-k and public K through 12 schools he
wants to restrict offshore oil drilling
and address climate change he's kind of
moderately on the right track when it
comes to health care he wants to stand
against ice and has been not against ice
like the freezing of water but against
the immigration agency ice he's been
clear that Virginia's doors are open to
immigrants now gun control he could
probably be better but it is Virginia
after all but you might be asking well
why do we care right it's a Virginia
Democratic governor replacing a Virginia
Democratic governor well there's three
major reasons that I think this is an
important race number one I'm gonna
forget the third one just to be like
Rick Perry but I'm telling you now that
there's three reasons number one a
Democrat replacing a Democrat is better
than a Republican replacing a Democrat
in Virginia okay so that's like very
easy top-level number two it is a less
establishment corporate type Democrat
slightly replacing a completely
corporate Democrat in Terry McAuliffe so
that's a good thing especially in a
relatively purple state like
Virginia sometimes a red state like
Virginia and number three I didn't
really forget number three you didn't
think I was gonna forget the third one
did you this is how this is related to
Trump right this was seen as a sort of
test for the midterms in terms of the
Trump factor in the 2016 election Donald
Trump got 44% of the vote presidentially
in Virginia losing to Hillary Clinton
Trump's approval has dropped to 32 34 36
38 percent in Virginia and indeed
Gillespie kind of tied himself to Trump
that the Trump Gillespie dynamic was
weird because Trump did endorse
Gillespie and Gillespie basically ran on
a Trump like agenda but never fully tied
himself to Trump the individual and
immediately after we knew that Gillespie
had been defeated Trump took to Twitter
during his Asia trip and completely
threw Gillespie under the bus tweeting
tweeting that Ed Gillespie worked hard
but did not embrace me or what I stand
for
don't forget Republicans won four House
seats and the economy doing record
numbers we will continue to win even
better even bigger than before so this
is the pattern with Trump he'll endorse
you but then immediately throw you under
the bus as soon as you lose that was
Virginia but also good news yesterday
for Democrats in New Jersey
big-time Trump loser Chris Christie
Republican governor exiting New Jersey
with a record low approval rating and a
Democrat has taken over the governorship
there so the good news is we're going
from Republican to Democrat Phil Murphy
the Democrat defeating Republican kim
Guadagno
think that's how she pronounces her name
roughly 56 to 42 big loss for the
Republican candidate in the new jersey
governor ship the bad news is and this
is so vile that it is more of the Wall
Street cronyism that has been so common
among New Jersey governors New Jersey's
new governor elect Phil Murphy is a
former Goldman Sachs executive so yeah
there are some good signs here there are
some bad signs here and what this tells
us about the midterms is that it's time
to activate right it is time to activate
even before the midterms and
we've got this special Senate election
in Alabama where it is possible that
vile disgusting former judge Roy Moore
could be defeated by a Democrat in
Alabama which would be a major major
deal although it is not the most likely
scenario it's possible the polling is
relatively tight there you can get
involved in Alabama and then we're
moving on to the big to the midterms
we're going to Iowa we're going to
Pennsylvania we're going to wherever
we're going everywhere wherever it was
that Howard Dean wanted to go on that
fateful day and I don't even know what
year that was 2004 yeah wherever it was
Dean wanted to go we're going there and
also Democrat Danica Rome became the
first the only openly transgender state
lawmaker in America she defeated Bob
Marshall and that is exactly what I
don't want to talk about next because it
is such an amazing story the video you
just finished watching was made possible
by you through the membership program
you can sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership